blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman i spent
some time
yesterday talking about how the um
reflexive reaction from the republicans
in charge of the state of texas
to the power outages that are happening
tragically
in the wake of a storm and cold weather
were
blamed on anything on the left that
republicans could come up with we talked
about them blaming
the green new deal which of course
hasn't happened we talked about them
blaming wind turbines which of course
represent just a small fraction
of the energy generation in texas and
the truth is as
philip bump writes in the washington
post and a really good article that i
encourage you to check out
it has been extraordinarily misleading
what republicans have done when it comes
to
pointing fingers and and placing blame
in the state of texas for what is going
on
uh of course anybody talking about the
green new deal is
ignoring or misleading in the sense that
none of what texas decided to do with
their power grid
has anything to do with the green new
deal other than the fact that they've
done
a little bit of wind power okay and a
little bit of solar power
but the reality is that that represents
a very small percentage of texas's uh
power generation
and the truth about what's going on in
texas is a combination of
republicans who have opted in order to
avoid
what they call federal regulation of
their energy
markets have their own uh power grid
whereas just about i mean i i don't want
to go
hyperbolic but almost every other part
of the world
has a broader more interconnected power
grid
than just one state the way texas has
that puts texas at significant risk
in exactly situations like this but it's
not just that
it's also that they had a decade to deal
with exactly the issue they're having
now as we talked about yesterday
texas had a similar power outage
situation in 2011.
a report was done tons of money was
spent on figuring out what happened and
how do you prevent it
from happening again and they figured
out how to prevent it from happening
again and it includes the
winterization of wind turbines but more
importantly
of instruments at natural gas
coal and nuclear power plants which are
the majority of texas
energy and they didn't do it they they
opted not
to do that other states that have wind
power
and other types of cap power and it gets
cold places like
montana and wyoming and others they've
done the winterization so when it gets
cold the wind turbines work everything
works fine
okay so this is an example of a
republican stronghold
blaming a problem they in some cases
it's caused in some cases it's failed to
deal with
on democrats or the left or
progressivism or climate science or
whatever the case may be
and this is a trend this is something
that they have been doing
on the right for a very long time the
right does tax cuts
and the tax cuts rather than helping the
economy
don't help the economy because they give
the tax cuts to the rich and trickle
down doesn't actually work
and somehow they blame democrats they'll
do tax cuts for the rich and say this is
going to be great
it's not and then they say oh well the
problem is democratic social
programs the tax cuts for the rich would
have worked
were it not for the democratic social
programs the housing disaster in 2008
which of course was the result of under
regulation
of mortgages and uh of derivatives
from mortgages including the packaging
up of mortgages and selling them
we've talked about that really it's a
problem of under regulation for a very
long time
uh primarily under george w bush or most
acutely under george w bush
they said it's a cop you know take your
pick the list of things they blamed is
very
very long but some combination of uh
democratic policy
in cities that uh created a problem with
housing prices
no the problem was under regulation led
by republicans dating back to
the sort of ideology of reagan in the
1980s the deregulation of the energy
industry more broadly
that's part of what we're seeing in
texas but but not only that has not been
good for states that have adopted it as
states have deregulated
energy under the idea of we want to give
people choice
and we want more competition and players
in the market everything from scams to
exploding prices have taken place
and by the way uh not with any increased
reliability when it comes to energy
but they blame it on the left um kansas
a very much uh cautionary tale
republicans including
the the governor there sam brownback
bankrupting kansas
going all in on trickle-down economics
and tax cuts for the rich or whatever
else
um completely bankrupting kansas failing
to grow
the business base and the revenue base
and blaming democrats incoherently
they are now blaming covet deaths
and the fact that although coveted
deaths are i mean listen to the numbers
covid deaths are down 37 percent from
their peak a month ago
they are blaming covet deaths which they
didn't even seem to care about when
donald trump was president
40 of which were avoidable on joe biden
already
despite donald trump failing to control
it for nearly a full year
many of these stories in some way are
about either deregulation
or when it comes to covid not enough
federal government involvement but they
continue to
create these disasters blame it on
democrats even though they are the ones
in power
and also blame it on the ideology that
is the opposite of what they want when
really they should be looking at their
policies of getting government quote out
of people's lives
deregulation and so on if they're not so
so the the
the pattern is if they're in power and
there's a disaster they blame it on
democrats
because democrats somehow prevented them
from doing what they really wanted to do
or did something that played as a
counterweight to what they did
if republicans aren't in power they'll
just say democrats are in power so it's
their fault
even if their obstructionism is actually
what caused the problem
sort of like spoiled children no
accountability
no integrity no personal responsibility
they take credit for everything and
responsibility for nothing
much like donald trump i mean it's
donald trump took that idea that we've
seen republicans put into place over the
last 45
40 years and just exploded it to the
110th
percentile and unfortunately
it doesn't seem like things are super
quickly going to get any better in texas
i want to talk about that next
texas republicans seem to have a thing
about volunteering
other people to do things that maybe
they don't want to do
remember back in the earlier phases of
the virus
in texas when texas republican
lieutenant governor dan patrick went on
tv and said listen
grandma would sacrifice herself to save
the economy by which
he really met the stock market and then
we said well
grandma isn't dan patrick's to sacrifice
now former texas republican governor and
former trump secretary of energy rick
perry
is saying texans are willing to continue
going without power
so that the federal government doesn't
get involved in their energy market
it's not his role to decide who wants to
go without power
in a blog that was posted on house
minority leader kevin mccarthy's website
rick perry wrote quote
texans would be without electricity for
longer than three days
to keep the federal government out of
their business how does he know that
try not to let whatever the crisis of
the day is take your eye off
of having a resilient grid that keeps
america
safe personally economically and
strategically
personal responsibility right rick perry
can say what he wants
what he's willing to do but who is he to
say
how many days other texans are willing
to go without power
or heat or water for political reasons
what he is saying here is some of you
may die
to keep our power unregulated by the
federal government but that's a
sacrifice
i am volunteering you to make what
for people who maybe aren't up to speed
on this issue understandably
texas has a power power grid that's run
by
i believe the the acronym is ercot
e-r-c-o-t
and it's the only power grid in the in
the united states that doesn't cross
state lines
and as a result of that it's not under
the oversight of the federal
energy regulatory commission rick perry
likes that a lot of texas republican
elected officials like that
um and what rick perry is saying here is
because he wants to keep that going
it's the equivalent of saying listen
americans are willing to have an extra
fifty thousand dollar
ex extra fifty thousand people die of
covid so that we don't get controlled by
the who or something like that that's
essentially the equivalent of what rick
perry is saying
now first of all i doubt it from
everybody i'm talking to in texas
nobody even libertarians and other
people
nobody seems okay with what's going on
so that they can maintain their
independence
from any other grids in federal
oversight secondly
it's not rick perry's call to make
if there's a power outage others are
willing to die
for rick perry's separatist views
no that that's that that just can't be
and one other thing on this
i've said despite the hypocrisy of texas
republicans like ted cruz demanding
federal relief money for texas
now but was against federal relief money
when it was needed in new york and new
jersey for hurricane sandy
despite him being a disgusting hypocrite
i don't want texans to go without
federal aid i still want the people of
texas to get the relief money because
they need it i don't want to
hold it back from them because ted cruz
is a hypocrite but there is a real
question here about
if texas refuses to become part of a
bigger broader interstate
resilient power grid should they
continue to be bailed out by the feds
there are options for preventing this by
being part of a multi-state power grid
and they refuse
but then they still want the money when
it fails again
i don't want to deny the people of texas
anything but shouldn't someone make it
clear to texas
you've got to join us if you want us to
bail you out you have to join the power
grid because otherwise
you're bringing this problem on
yourselves they had power outages in
2011 for similar reasons
they got a report telling them how to
prevent this from happening again
they didn't do anything that the report
said and now they immediately and
defiantly
say give us the cash there has to be
some limit at some point
and somebody needs to sit ted cruz down
and talk about it except ted cruz flew
to cancun in the middle of all of this i
want to talk about that next
uh senator ted cruz republican of texas
millions of whose constituents are
without power without hot water
uh having trouble getting food he
demanded
federal money for texas after voting
against federal money from new york and
new jersey during hurricane sandy
and then he flew to cancun with his
family in the middle of what's going on
our friend david shuster tweeted a
picture of ted cruz on an airplane
with his family and the caption just
confirmed
senator ted cruz and his family flew to
cancun tonight
for a few days at a resort they visited
before
cruz seems to believe there isn't much
for him to do in texas for the millions
of fellow texans who remain
without electricity water and are
literally freezing that was early this
morning
um this is uh
i mean i hate to say it but this is this
is more
more of the same this is the
prototypical republican
no money for new york and new jersey
because it's pork and it's money we
don't have
oh texas is in trouble yes give us the
money
i'll be in cancun with my family on the
beach though
meanwhile just for comparison
beto o'rourke was phone banking
to elderly texans to see how they were
doing
okay ted cruz votes against money for
new york and new jersey when it's not
his constituents
says give me the money even though he
was part of resisting integrating the
elect
the electrical grid in texas into other
grids
says give us the money now because it's
my constituents but i'm going to go on
vacation anyway
there is a difference here okay we talk
about republicans and democrats very
similar on too many issues
not much breathing room between them but
there is a difference here and this is a
moral difference
this is an ethical difference this is
also an ideological difference
about what it means to be an elected
official when your constituents
are in crisis and ted cruz no surprise
continues to be exactly the disgusting
guy that we know him to be
we'll take a quick break find me on
twitter at d pacman we'll be back after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show doesn't have a
money tree on which cash grows
we actually do depend on the support of
folks
like you who get memberships at
joinpacman.com so consider doing that
today you'll get access to the daily
bonus show and extra show for our
members
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show exciting stuff
sign up at joinpackman.com also i invite
you to join the discussion on the david
pakman show subreddit nearly
30 000 if you can imagine nearly 30
000 of our viewers and listeners are now
subscribed to the david pakman show
subreddit you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts i spotted
this morning
one asks why do trumpus need to believe
that antifa was behind the january 6th
insurrection
hear me out says this user let's imagine
the insane world that the trumpets live
in is reality
the election was stolen from trump and
there was rampant fraud in favor of joe
biden it was rigged at every level
and joe biden is a illegitimate
president if this is the case then don't
trump supporters have the moral
obligation to take back their country
and reinstall trump as president
since he was rightly elected after all
the declaration of independence says the
people have a right to alter or abolish
an illegitimate government
going on to say my point is this under
the premise that the election was truly
stolen
then they shouldn't need to blame antifa
for the riot since the people at the
capitol
should have gone even farther in their
actions to prevent biden from becoming
president
in other words none of the trumpist
republicans should be condemning the
insurrectionist or blaming antifa
they should be embracing their actions
of the the actions of the
insurrectionists instead
this is a very important point and this
is something that we've been talking
about for a long time which is
very often these radical conspiratorial
hypotheses from the right conflict
and this is this is the epitome of that
on the one hand you have people who for
two months
following the lead of trump and rudy
giuliani and all these other people
believed the election was really stolen
joe biden didn't really win donald trump
actually won if that actually is true
then of course they would go to the
capitol on january 6th
and again they went because they did
believe that that was true
so then why would they be blaming antifa
they really would be there
as people demanding that the rightful
winner of the presidential election be
installed
it would be trumpists that would go you
wouldn't need to point the finger at
antifa are we meant to believe now
that they really believe the election
was stolen and they were willing to do
whatever it took just like donald trump
said you've got to fight for it just
like rudy said trial by
combat or whatever it was but then they
didn't actually go on january 6th they
stayed home
even though they were ready and willing
to fight for their president no
it's incoherent and this is very
accurately pointing it out
another interesting post from the
subreddit argues
that good republicans don't exist this
user says
there is no rot within the republican
party the republican party
is the rot right down to its moldy core
everything republicans stand for is
wrong politically they stand for tax
cuts for the rich
d unionization sucking off the
military-industrial complex
trickle-down economics and brown people
are bad ideologically they stand for
lgbtq is bad women's rights is bad
more votes bad brown people bad again
living wages or socialism
affordable health care socialism
fighting climate changes socialism on
and on and they go on to say tell me
honestly
what actual honest to
bat christ good comes from the continued
existence of the republican party what's
a single
genuinely good thing they do for the
american people and not just the one
percent the wealthiest one percent of
their base
and um to to a great degree this is true
and uh what i mean by that is there are
people
who i disagree with politically
uh but who i don't think are out of
their mind
bad people necessarily in the republican
party
moderate republicans whose priorities
are they
are socially i don't want to say
socially liberal
but socially libertarian let's say um
and really genuinely believe that you
know regulation's not
socialism but uh that the country is
better off with less
regulation and lower taxes and whatever
okay i mean these these are political
disagreements
as sold as uh as old as government
itself
but to a great degree this is accurate
where you have essentially the worst
instincts of just bad people coalesced
around
um really horrible leaders donald trump
being the the sort of greatest example
of that
and they make a lot of good points as i
think the point i would make
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit all right uh i want to warn
everybody
there is some trump content on today's
program
donald trump after being essentially out
of the public eye for the last two
months of his presidency
and since leaving the white house did a
bunch of interviews yesterday
uh in a sense he did four if you include
his bizarre
call-in to eulogize rush limbaugh
on fox news which we'll talk about a
little bit later uh he did another
another late night interview on fox news
with sean hannity which we'll cover
tomorrow
he did an interview with oan which i
won't cover at all
but he did a news max interview which is
where i want to start today
and the big picture of this interview is
that donald trump has learned
absolutely nothing from being president
he has learned nothing from losing
in november he has just decided to
continue making his false claims
that he won the election that joe biden
stole it
now let's see if we can learn anything
from this interview let's jump right in
the topic of rush limbaugh's death came
up donald trump took it as an
opportunity to tell
the big lie once again that he won the
election and that rush
limbaugh believed it as well you know
just got he just got a bad
a bad deal with uh what hit what he had
with something was not going to be
beaten
it was not going to be beaten and he
understood that but he wanted to get
past the election and he made it easily
and he thought we won the election we
did win the election so as i'm concerned
it was
disgraceful what happened totally
disgraceful but russia wanted to get
by the election and he did it and he was
proud of that
the casual nature with with which
donald trump still says after causing
the riot
that he won confirms he learned
absolutely nothing and then donald trump
just like he used to bragging about
fake polls in which he is supposedly now
beloved he was asking the big question
uh he was asked the big question about
running in 2024
he didn't commit but he had many other
things to say see if you can make sense
out of any of them
we have tremendous support i won't say
yet but we have tremendous support
and i'm looking at poll numbers that are
through the roof you saw what happened
yesterday we went up we get i'm the only
guy gets
in peach and my numbers go up i might
figure that one out let's say somebody
gets impeached typically your numbers
would go down
they would go down like uh like a dead
balloon
but the numbers are very good they're
very high i think they're higher than
they were before the election
and they were high at the election and
they liked the job look we did a great
job we
we built rebuilt our military think of
it we lowered taxes got rid of
regulations
how about space force just space force
alone would be a big achievement first
time in 74 years
a new branch of the u.s military so you
know all of the things we've done
what on earth is donald trump talking
about his numbers are good and high
he lost the election by a record number
of votes and while
yes the majority of the republican
electorate still is behind trump even
those numbers have tapered off a little
bit
also it's not like there are that many
examples of approval ratings
during impeachments he says oh typically
approval ratings are down during
impeachment mine were up
bill clinton did fine in approval while
being impeached
before that it was before the polling
era so on the basic facts as usual
donald trump is just wrong or
clueless this same type of
verbal rorschach tests that we've become
accustomed to during trump's presidency
um were continuing as we are left to try
to kind of unravel and decipher what
trump is talking about listen to this
and the border we built the wall mexico
was
all getting ready to pay for the wall we
were going to charge him at the border
small fee
and mexico would have paid for the wall
they were all set they gave us 28 000
troops to police it before it got built
and now you see what's happening and the
president of mexico is a great gentleman
by the way
but he put 28 000 troops on our border
at my request
and we didn't pay for that and he we
kept we kept the border beautiful and
now you take a look at what's going on
at the border it's a disgrace it's a
disgrace hundreds of thousands of people
are going to be pouring in
mexico was never going to pay for the
wall that lie
won't die trump now wants us to believe
that he was
just seconds away from putting in place
some kind of a border
tax on people coming in from mexico to
indirectly pay for the wall
he was never going to do it he's been
talking about it for years it didn't
matter if he got a second term or not he
just won't stop telling that lie
but it's simply a lie and just all over
the place and if you were
watching there you might have seen when
the camera cut back to the host greg
kelly on newsmax
he looks sort of exasperated and looking
around and thinking of how
he might be able to get control back of
the interview something that's pretty
tough to do
donald trump then asked about being
suspended from twitter
and this got really weird trump sort of
listed
the number of followers he believed he
had
on on various networks and claims that
twitter very is very boring now without
him
i mean just the opposite they really
wanted me on parlor
and you know i had 89 million but that
was because they held it back and then
on top of that i had 36 million or 39
million on potus
and we had other sites where we had
millions and millions of people so we
have
i guess about as big as it gets and
likewise on
on facebook and they all want that and
part of the problem is
mechanically they can't handle it
because it's too many people it's bigger
than they are by many times
and they want to uh and i'll tell you
it's not the same if you look at what's
going on with uh
if you look at what's going on with
twitter i understand it's become very
boring
and millions of people are leaving
they're leaving it because it's not the
same and i can understand that
and so we'll see what happens we're
we're negotiating with a number of
people
and there's also the other option of
building your own something you can
literally build your own set but we were
being really harassed on twitter
did you notice that he said there that
part of the problem
is that his following is too big i guess
for
facebook to handle on a technical level
that
it's just such a ridiculous thing to say
mechanically they can't handle it like
what is he talking about
and it doesn't matter how obviously
untrue these things are
donald trump has a unique ability to
tell
laughable obvious provable lies
as if there's nothing to it just so
casually telling them
and that was the newsmax interview greg
kelly visibly struggling to get control
of it
tomorrow we're going to look at the
hannity interview which
is a whole other level to look at i want
i don't even have time today to devote
to it i'm going to save it for tomorrow
but we'll take a break later we will
talk about rush limbaugh and i have i
have quite a few things
i want to go over with rush limbaugh and
we'll have some clips of trump calling
into fox
during the daytime to you eulogize rush
in a way that is completely self-serving
and narcissistic what else would you
expect
uh so trump out of the bunker back on
media we'll have more coverage of it
on the instagram page follow us on
instagram
at davidpakmanshow and you can follow me
on instagram
david.pac the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you is high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
because of everything that's been going
on in texas this week this tragic
mismanagement combined with denial of
climate science and so many other things
that have led to
millions of people in texas ending up
without power
uh people in austin being told to boil
water
which many of them can't do because they
don't have power and they're relying on
either
an electric microwave or an electric
oven and stove
that they would need to boil the water
that needs to be boiled because power is
out at the water treatment plant so this
chaos
goes back a long time we know this
because in 2011
similar uh power outages happened in
texas a report was issued explaining
what texas needs to do in order to
protect themselves in situations like
this and they didn't do it
but i want to go back to an interview i
did a few years ago with
gretchen bakke about exactly
the relationship between the electrical
grid
a green alternative renewable energy
the conflicts that exist because of
business interests
and politics and so many other things so
could not be a more relevant time
to revisit this interview with gretchen
let's get right into it i'm joined today
by gretchen bakke who is author of the
grid the fraying wires between
americans and our energy future gretchen
it's so great to talk to you know we
talk so much about the
move towards alternative and renewable
sources of energy
we talk about the political implications
and and the sort of economic
implications but one thing that's often
missing from that conversation
is sort of the reality of the electrical
grid that we're working with
and some of the limitations that exist
and will sort of have to be dealt with
if we really want to move away from
fossil fuels which i believe that we
should be uh
trying to do let's start as broadly as
you want to i mean what are some of the
limitations that need to be considered
well i think the main thing that people
don't quite grasp when there's when
when when thinking about the energy
transition is that electricity can't
really be stored
right now and what that means is that as
it's made it's used it's this very
instantaneous
product so as it's made it's used and
that means that if we make it with
something like
coal it's a very steady production and
if we make it with something like wind
it's a very unsteady production
um because the amount of electricity
changes
as the as the rate of the wind blowing
changes
um and so that's called variable
generation and it's the
more of it that we put into our grid we
tend to think of it as renewables but
not all renewables are variable
and the more we put of it we put into
the grid the
the harder it is to manage this sort of
perfect balancing
of how much electricity we use in any
instant and how much electricity we
produce
in that same instant uh because
electricity is
essentially instantaneous so almost
never more than a minute between when
it's made and when it's used
and this is particularly relevant for
people who already have or are thinking
of
of moving to solar power in their home
unless you actually have a means of
storing electricity right unless you
have an
actual battery setup any excess
electricity
that is harvested by your home solar
system
is not stored for your future use but
rather goes back into the grid and as
you mentioned is almost instantaneously
used
by someone else i mean is that generally
the way that it works
yeah and i think that's one of the
things that i was really confused about
for a long time was why people could
have diesel generators
and seem to be like when there was a
blackout they would be able to
power things in their house but if you
have solar panels you can't
um and like many people i thought that
was something that the utilities were on
somehow
scheming to make it that you so you
couldn't go off the grid completely
but actually diesel generators have all
these very heavy pieces inside of them
and so
when you turn on a light switch there's
a kind of inertial force
inside the generator that allows it to
balance your house
so the the power you have on or turning
on or turning off at any moment
it has to be balanced by the amount of
electricity that generator is producing
so again the fossil fuel and then this
heavy piece of equipment
enable you to run your house even
without storage
whereas solar panels obviously you're
not going to have any
any power at night but even so you turn
on your light
there's no way for so for a solar panel
to adjust to that
without some kind of storage so you turn
on a light you're asking for more
electricity from that system but that
system is just producing electricity
based on how much sun is hitting it at
that moment
um and you know we don't use we don't
even think in terms
of like okay it's midday and it's really
sunny so i'm going to run
everything right now right our fridge
turns on our freezer turns on it goes
off we turn on the lights we turn them
off
um and all of that has to be balanced in
some way by
something and right now that something
is the grid
and people like the grid it's not
there's not a there's not really a
strong
movement i think against the grid but
there is this sense of like why can't i
be energy independent and the reason for
that is
when you turn on a light and you have
solar panels
that extra electricity needs to come
from somewhere so it comes
through the grid um and if the grid is
down
then it doesn't it doesn't come from
anywhere and is part of the path
forward on this i mean elon musk from
tesla has talked about
the home battery systems that they're
working on
that within a few years he says will be
relatively affordable i mean is
is that the type of solution that you
see is the most likely to this problem
i think it's very hard to see the future
because i think that people
really like the idea of being part of a
larger electricity system it's it was
very rare in my research that i found
people that wanted to wanted some kind
of energy
wanted to be isolated all the time
they're happy to produce
for the grid um solar panels in
particular like very happy to produce
for the grid during the daytime to
to draw from the grid at night time so i
think that
that there is a possibility certainly
with those home battery storage systems
that you could be energy independent all
the time so you wouldn't need the grid
at all
um but i think what's more likely is
that people will start to use those so
that
they have power when the power is out on
the larger system
interesting and and that was a lot of
what was happening when i was doing my
research is that a lot of the
frustration i found
with the electricity system part of it
was this feeling of like we want more
renewables
um which is which is very hard to manage
and i think there's a lot of work going
in that direction
by people who do manage the grid right
now but not fast enough
right there's there's a lot of anger
with the utilities in particular for not
making that transition quickly enough
but the other big frustration was my
power's out all the time
i have solar panels why can't i just
have my power be on
like why do i have to also have a diesel
backup generator
um so this movement from from producing
power independently but
also trying to be green at home and
wanting the larger electricity system to
be green as well
so if we step aside a little bit from
the storage aspect of it i'd love to
talk a little bit about some of the
other ways in which the grid is
relatively
susceptible to outside forces i mean we
have mostly in this country
elevated power lines where anything from
weather to a squirrel
can cause pretty significant
interruptions is that one of the biggest
sort of liabilities in the american
electrical grid right now
um you mean the the power lines being
above ground
yeah certainly certainly it's uh it is
in part because the greatest threat to
the grid right now is growing trees
so if they were underground that would
be less of a problem it's really hard to
cut back
all of the foliage that is just up and
coming over this huge nation right it's
always just going up and up and up and
sort of grabbing at power lines
um so yes it's not always the answer to
barry though
if you have some place like florida with
a high
sort of a high tidal i don't know i
think the word is scale but the water
comes up very high
tidally or when when it's very wet you
don't want to bury
um you don't want to bury lines and you
don't even want um critical
infrastructure at ground level you want
to start putting stuff up you want to
put your substations on hills
um so for some places it's quite it's
quite a good idea to bury lines um in
other places it's a less good idea
the grid is weirdly local so we have
three of them in the u.s and they're
each gigantic they're these huge
machines are sort of one for the west
one for the east and one for texas
but nevertheless it's also extremely
local in how it's designed how different
states have
been keeping it up the kinds of laws
there are laws that are federal but
there are many laws that are very um
particular to states or even to counties
or to municipalities
um so taking into account the weather in
particular places matters
for answering that question um but it's
also extremely expensive to bury lines
yeah and that also gets towards what's
sort of underlying this which is uh
i don't know if i would call it a
jurisdictional issue but certainly one
of ownership which is that
there's not like a single entity that
owns or controls or maintains
the grid right i mean as you're sort of
talking about you're talking about
municipalities and a lot of smaller
entities that are part of this grid
and even manage their own grid um there
are many municipal like
los angeles for example has it manages
its own
grid even though that grid is connected
into um the entire
gigantic grid which covers the whole of
the west it's still that particular
piece of it like
where they're buying electricity from
how much they're paying for it who's
maintaining the lines um
all of that is is managed by the
municipality and
some municipal grids are very very small
i i talk about in the book rancho
cucamonga which has one streetlight
but they have a municipal power um
municipal power governance um and people
again are sort of organizing suburbs etc
as they get frustrated with
the rate of change um
to a more renewable renewably powered
system they are they'll they'll just get
towns or suburbs together and they'll
they'll disaggregate it's called from
the big grid and take over their own
little
um piece of it to manage it for
themselves um so that's sort of that's a
that happens legally in the states so
it's both big and
you know very very small um very very
local
um and absolutely you know nationally
gigantic
and i think that's where you see a lot
of the excitement about what's happening
right now i know most people don't
really see the grid or think about the
grid but it's
it's changing radically at this exact
moment in time
and lots of people are causing that
change to happen in different ways
well it is a hugely important issue
particularly when we have the
conversation about
when and how will we get off of fossil
fuels it's something that that could not
be more important again we've been
talking about the book the grid
the fraying wires between americans and
our energy future
and we've been speaking with the book's
author gretchen bakke thanks so much for
talking to us about this
yeah my pleasure thank you the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous
at this point and the daily commercial
free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
radical right-wing radio host rush
limbaugh in many ways
the father of modern right-wing
political media in in uh we could say
that actually in a number of different
ways
has died at the age of 70
from lung cancer which we learned about
a year ago
that he had you may recall that
shortly after his diagnosis donald trump
awarded him the presidential medal of
freedom during the state of the union
address
in the year 2020 he has died
and this has brought out it's really
brought out
the worst of many people but also
understandable
ire and in a sense relief that rush
limbaugh will no longer be on the
american airwaves
and i've received so many emails about
this
some people gleeful at the death of rush
limbaugh
others more circumspect and i want to be
sort of super clear i don't believe in
participating in cheering
people's illness or death nor do i
ever wish illness or death upon anyone
and
at the same time as adults most of us
we can recognize that some people have a
positive influence in the world
and some people have a negative
influence in the world and rush
limbaugh's influence on the world was
disgustingly
and decidedly and unquestionably
negative and disastrously so rush
limbaugh used to do a segment
where he would celebrate when people
with aids died
as written by mary strom larson quote he
garnered a following
with outrageous programming that
includes
such features as celebratory moments
when another aids victim died which he
called
aids updates that is disgusting
it knows no bounds that is that is the
lower than anything
he regularly referred to
women who i guess believe in women's
rights as feminine nazis
he regularly um took
pleasure in the death of people on the
left here he is
rush limbaugh gleeful at the death of
former supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg just
ecstatic at the possibility that it
presents
for the right to further take over the
supreme court
washington post has a story today
democrats
largely powerless to stop the gop
from confirming their court choice folks
do you know how big this is
this is huge this could be
i want to whisper this the end of roe
versus wade but but
this is going to have a
massive impact on the american judiciary
it's thus going to have a massive
impact on american culture and society
so this is absolutely and endlessly
disgusting so
listen i've been seeing the post i've
been getting the messages i've been
seeing the tweets of people
essentially doing a dance on rush
limbaugh's grave that that's not in my
constitution to do that just doesn't
feel right
and so i don't do it uh when rush
limbaugh was diagnosed with lung cancer
i didn't cheer
rush limbaugh has a family i don't know
if he has kids i guess maybe he does i
mean listen
he he's a terrible he was a terrible
person uh
but illness and death affect people and
i i would never wish that on anyone but
there is no doubt that we can recognize
this person was an absolutely terrible
influence on american politics
he was responsible for
much of the um not just you know
coarsening of language is sort of like
okay coarsening of language but
the normalization of a certain type of
gutter sniping
politics uh during his early days on
radio
and uh the world was um
what was negatively affected by his
presence on the airwaves so rush
limbaugh dead at 70.
uh and those are my thoughts and quite
frankly i don't i don't feel the need to
say too much more about it
but i do want to talk a little bit uh
about donald trump's
bizarre rambling self-centered eulogy
for rush on fox news so yesterday after
we learned
about the death of rush limbaugh radical
right-wing radio host who celebrated the
death of ruth bader ginsburg
would celebrate the deaths of aids
victims that rush limbaugh
died yesterday at age 70 of lung cancer
donald trump appeared on fox news during
the day in advance of his nighttime
interviews on oan newsmax and fox news
trump called into fox news during the
day
sort of to eulogize rush limbaugh
but it was a very strange appearance and
uh
it was self-centered and it was rambling
and it was everything that at this point
we would expect from donald trump
so let's jump right into it he is
succumbed to tears
and i was curious what did he know was
coming
so i did tell him beforehand because we
didn't
have the uh really the the
power of not doing it you know rush was
very sick at the time
he was at a hospital in boston and i
didn't want to do the surprise thing
uh i wish i wish i could have done that
but we really didn't have that
that that power of doing it because he
had
it was a very difficult thing for him to
come into
washington from where he was and he did
it and there was questions as to whether
or not he was just a very brave guy he's
amazing
and he came in and it was as he told me
it was the greatest honor of his life
and everybody in the room uh you know
you're talking about
the republicans and the democrats you
had half of that room went
crazy you remember the evening well i'm
sure it's very unique moment
yeah in our country's history in a sense
because of who russia is but
halfway just absolutely crazy the other
half sat
totally dead silent but a hundred
percent of that room
respected rush so complete delusions of
grandeur of course
it was a great moment in our country's
history
when a radical right-wing radio host got
a medal from donald trump
basically just a reward for sucking up
to donald trump if
that's a notable moment in american
history
when rush limbaugh degraded the meaning
of the presidential medal of freedom
well really it was trump who degraded
the meaning of it
and the value by awarding it to rush
limbaugh if that is a notable
moment in american history it says
something very sad about the country now
i don't believe that obviously there are
many notable moments in american history
trump handing the medal of freedom to a
right-wing radio
host because the hit radio host
supported trump not exactly ranking high
in uh in in moments of american history
and
of course that's why donald trump likes
rush limbaugh
because rush supported donald trump and
it's not true uh we heard in
trump in trump's hannity interview which
we'll look at tomorrow trump repeated
the same line
this line of democrats respected rush
limbaugh no they didn't rush limbaugh
did disgusting and depraved things
on air he attacked women he attacked
gays
he attacked you know just people on the
left in general
he gleefully he was gleeful when ruth
bader ginsburg died he would
celebrate the deaths of aids patients
during the 90s what
democrats didn't respect rush limbaugh
what on earth is trump talking about but
let's continue
it was a unique guy and he was a he
became a friend of mine you know i
didn't know rush
at all i had essentially never met rush
and then when we came down the escalator
he
liked my rather controversial speech i
made that speech that was a little bit
on the controversial side and he loved
it
and he was without ever having met him
or talked to him or you know had lunch
with him and
asked him he was with me right from the
beginning
and he liked what i said and he agreed
with what i said
and he was just a great gentleman great
great man and of course
that's what this is all about
rush was with trump to trump that's all
that matters trump doesn't so much
trump often talks about my friends
he doesn't really have friends he has
yes men
and sycophants who he allows to remain
around him
for as long as they remain yes men and
sycophants that's what donald trump has
and that's how donald trump's
relationships work that's how he
evaluates other people
trump then uses rush limbaugh's death
to repeat the long debunked lies
about the election that trump actually
won and
that rush believed it harris what did
rush limbaugh tell you
after the election of november 3rd what
were those conversations like
well rush thought we won and so do i by
the way i i think we won
substantially and rush thought we won
and uh he thought it was over at 10
o'clock 10 30 it was over
and a lot of other people feel that way
too but rush felt that way strongly
and many people do many professionals do
and
i don't think that could have happened
to a democrat you would have had
you would have had riots going all over
the place if that happened to a democrat
we don't have the same support
in the at certain levels of the
republican system but we have great
people as republicans
of course that was russia's big thing
calling trump up and saying sir they
stole it from you
joe biden didn't really win and trump
going
directly into his election fraud talking
points there repeating
all the same stuff what a great
coincidence right
that rush limbaugh thought the exact
same thing so there's donald trump's
initial sort of bizarre eulogy of rush
limbaugh
he supported me and he agreed the
election was stolen
so he was great well said sir really
nicely done and tomorrow we're going to
look at
donald trump's interview with sean
hannity where he actually it's not like
urgent so i don't feel the need to get
to it today we don't have time
but tomorrow i do want to look into it
because there's some interesting stuff
about 2024
um oh some interesting anecdotes so
tomorrow night we will look or tomorrow
on tomorrow's podcast rather we will
look at last night's interview that
donald trump did
with sean hannity uh in the meantime
we'll have to leave it there for today
much to the dismay
but also pleasure of different people in
our audience
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
here's a very interesting voicemail i
realized from looking at the email and
looking at comments about our
vaccine-related stories
that this is actually a confusion that a
lot of folks have so listen to this then
i'll address it
david pakman big fan thank you
hey there i have a question about
the daily vaccine count yeah i've
addressed this
but i i can't quite find an answer
when we say 2.2 or 2.3 million people
vaccinated
in one day does that mean
2.2 million shots given that day
does that mean 2.2 million people got
their
second dose and now are fully vaccinated
so i'm wondering if that how that count
is done
um again silly question if you could
just either answer it on the show you
don't have to put the message but
yeah no the message is a good one this
is this is a great question we are
talking about
doses okay so when we say 2.2 million
doses were given out
that's a combination of first and second
shots and
take the pfizer vaccine for example
which you have 21 days between shots
if today or let me i'll go backwards
imagine that 21 days ago
we gave out 800 000 pfizer shots and
then today
we give out 1.5 million pfizer shots
what that means is that today of the 1.5
million pfizer shots
800 000 if everything works right 800
000 were second doses for people who got
their first dose 21 days ago
and then 700 000 would be first doses
for people who will get their second
dose
21 days from now right now the approved
vaccines in the united states are two
dose vaccines so when we say 2 million
shots
we are talking about 2 million total but
that's only half of the vaccination
protocol
for uh each individual person they need
a second shot
soon it looks like the johnson johnson
vaccine is going to be approved that's a
one-shot
vaccine so in the future when we say oh
uh
we we did three million vaccines today
which would be
a great number that might be a number of
first and second doses of the pfizer
vaccine
a number of first and or second doses of
the modern vaccine
and then a bunch of johnson and johnson
doses which are the one
sole dose since it will be a one dose so
we are talking about doses
not people totally vaccinated the new
york times is a good vaccine tracker
which will tell you total number of
doses
number of people who have received one
dose or more
and number of people who have received
full uh two two dose
regimens and uh these numbers are all
going to be going up
soon and we are going to be tracking it
we have a great bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about joe biden's
apparent snub of the saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman i find it very
interesting and i kind of like the
direction biden is goading going
on not go he's not goading anybody going
on saudi relations
we will talk about facebook banning
australian users from sharing
or viewing news why are they doing this
very interesting story
and we will also talk about japan taking
action on this issue of social isolation
appointing a
minister of loneliness to help people
who are home
alone this is not just because of the
pandemic this relates to issues that
have been happening culturally in japan
for some time
which we've been talking about all of
those stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
a lot for watching today's show i just
want to take a second to tell you about
today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman